- "Study Finds 87% of
Chinese Takeout Eaten
by Team of Prosecutors Embroiled
in Late-Night Investigations."
I love that trope.
It's so funny that, you know,
whether it is prosecutors
or corporate lawyers,
they're all in front of a big
table, late into the night,
and then they just get box
after box of Chinese takeout.
And they have some brilliant idea
while shoving lo mein into their mouth.
The Onion is by far the best source
of satirical news on the internet.
And they have, on occasion,
taken shots at the legal profession.
But the best satire has a grain of truth.
So let's see how The Onion does
when they make legal headlines.
All right. So right off the bat.
"Jurisprudence Fetishist
Gets Off on a Technicality."
That's sick (beep).
Probably something twisted like SMJ.
Oh my God, I can't believe I just made
a subject matter jurisdiction/BDSM joke.
That is that, that is a heck
of a way to start this video.
Amazing.
"Ketanji Brown Jackson Weighs History
Against Soul-Crushing
Thought of Spending Time
with These People."
Ooh.
Okay, I really think that the thought
that the members of the
Supreme Court are not friends
with each other or at least
professional with each other,
I think that's completely overblown.
I think despite their
political differences,
I think probably most of the
people on the Supreme Court
are perfectly fine with each other
and the people on the Supreme Court
are perfectly fine human beings.
I don't think Ketanji Brown Jackson
will have much of a decision to make here.
She's gonna make history.
All right, "Class-Action Suit Against God
Pays Out 45 Extra Seconds
of Life to Every Creature."
Ooh, that hits close to the home.
Especially given the number
of class-action suits
I've covered.
"Calling it a historic victory
for all who have been victims
of the Lord's negligence,
lawyers represented the planet's estimated
20 quintillion animal
inhabitants announced Tuesday
that a class-action lawsuit against God
would pay out an extra 45
seconds of life to each creature.
Lead attorney Landon Burke
announced that anyone
who believed they were
owed restitution by God
could reply to the notice
they received in the mail
or sign up online to
receive their supplemental
45 seconds of life."
That's really funny
because that is often how
you have to provide the class
the restitution that they
get is through a postcard.
It's a whole thing in federal court
or going to this really janky website
that always looks like a scam.
Why do the class-action
websites always look terrible?
People don't sign up
because they think that
they're being scammed
when often it's legit.
I mean, class-action
lawsuits are notorious
for paying out really
small amounts of money
or coupons to the class.
Often the only people who get rich
are the class-action lawyers.
So actually in this
case, this is brilliant.
If you actually were
a plaintiff's attorney
and you got 45 seconds of life
for 20 quintillion animals,
then effectively, you're 30 or 40%
of that quintillion animals'
seconds times 45 seconds.
They'd live forever.
It's always the plaintiff's attorneys
who get tons and tons of money,
even if the class gets almost nothing.
Plaintiff's attorneys, man.
"Supreme Court Rules Gay Rights
Do Not Extend to Dessert."
That's, I mean, that's too
close to what actually happened.
"While homosexuals do have
the right to get married,
the right to equal treatment
does not cover instances
of pastry, cake, or candy."
All right, so the Supreme
Court case in question
is a little more nuanced than that,
but I get where they're
coming from on this one.
All right, "Man Who Never
Missed 'Ally McBeal'
Back in the Day Joins
the Trump Legal Team."
Oh boy, it seems like, it
seems like only yesterday
that we were dealing with Donald Trump
and his team of horrible,
horrible lawyers.
Honestly, if you were
comparing Rudy Giuliani
and Sydney Powell to someone
who never missed an episode
of "Ally McBeal," I think
that would be a fair fight.
That would probably be fine.
And the funniest thing about this article
is that it's from 2018.
The worst Trump lawyers
hadn't even been retained
at that point.
Man, we were so innocent back then.
"Christ Sues Catholic Church
for Unlicensed Use of His Image."
"I never signed off on, nor do I endorse,
the sentiments behind
any of these candles,
plates, statues, paintings, none of it.
I don't want to have my brand devalued
by a bunch of people just
trying to turn a quick buck
by slapping on a reproduction
of my wounded body
on a cross."
Ooh boy.
Yeah. I mean, frankly,
I'm not sure a whole bunch
of people wanna be associated
with the Catholic Church
after all of the headlines
that have been in the news
over the last couple of years.
Yeah. Especially Jesus.
But at the same time,
this is kind of similar
to that Lil Nas X issue
where he made the Satan shoes
and he also made the heaven shoes,
which was a whole thing with Nike
and they didn't want their
brand associated with it.
So I don't know.
I guess Nike is Jesus in
this particular scenario.
I'm gonna have to figure that one out.
That's interesting.
"New Uber Update Allows
Users to File Lawsuit
Against the Company Directly in the App."
Oh no, that's too true.
Oh God.
I wonder if those lawsuits
have quieted down.
I haven't heard much about
Uber getting sued these days.
I mean, there's the
whole thing in California
where it's a question of are
they misclassifying employees
as independent contractors?
But I mean, back in the day,
Uber had like 6,000 assault
allegations made against them
and they actually funded a
recovery fund of $4-5 million.
God, I hope that hasn't
continued to this day.
But man, you know, having
a button to be able
to sue Uber within its
own app, that would,
that'd probably be helpful.
Hopefully, they have
now cleaned up their act
and that's no longer an issue.
But it was, it was kind
of bad back in the day.
"Law School Applications
Increase Upon Realization
that Any (beep) Idiot Can Be a Lawyer."
Oh boy.
Yeah, I mean, in the wake
of the really crazy crack
in lawsuits, it really
did seem like anyone
could be a lawyer.
It goes to show you,
once you pass the bar,
it's really, really hard to
take someone's bar license away.
Though, I gotta say, they
sort of proved the impossible
in that a lot of them got sanctioned
and some of them were suspended.
We'll see what happens to Rudy Giuliani.
He may in fact lose his law license.
Seemingly doing the impossible.
We always knew he could do it.
"Study Finds 87% of Chinese Takeout Eaten
by Team of Prosecutors Embroiled
in Late-Night Investigations."
I love that trope.
It's so funny that, you know,
whether it is prosecutors
or corporate lawyers,
they're all in front of a big
table, late into the night,
and then they just get box
after box of Chinese takeout.
And they have some brilliant idea
while shoving lo mein into their mouths.
It's such a great TV trope.
I hope it never dies 'cause it's amazing.
Speaking of which,
"Everyone on Defense Team
An Equally Matched Romantic Interest
for Member of Prosecution."
This is such a great trope
that of course like
everyone on the defense team
has their counterpart on the prosecution
and they're gonna fall in love
and they will betray their
client for the greater good.
Such a wonderful trope.
"American Bar Association Recalls
230,000 Defective Lawyers."
Boo. Boo, I say.
Though, in fairness,
there's probably way more
than 230,000 defective lawyers.
That's how many new lawyers, I think,
are created or at least
how many law students
there are in the country
at any given time.
So there's probably a lot more
than 230,000 defective lawyers.
I hate to be the one to say it.
None that I've ever worked with.
The lawyers who have
been members of my firms
have all been outstanding
and have not been defective
in any way, shape, or form.
It's always opposing counsel
that's the defective one.
- Your Honor, I object!
- You would.
- Now whether you are a lawyer
or just want to think like one,
you can make sure you're not defective
with logic or math with a course
from today's sponsor, Brilliant.
Brilliant is an online
learning platform for STEM
that replaces lecture videos
with hands-on interactive lessons.
Brilliant is for curious learners
both young and old,
professional and inexperienced.
And one of my favorite
courses is all about logic.
Brilliant's logic courses cover
liar and truth-teller
riddles, logical fallacies,
machine logic, and even
some strategic game theory.
Logic is a crucial skill
that lawyers need every day.
And Brilliant lets you learn by doing
rather than listening to
hours of boring lectures.
Learning through doing
is scientifically proven
to be the most effective
way to master any new skill.
The courses have storytelling,
interactive challenges,
and problems to solve.
And within Brilliant's library,
you'll find courses and
topics like calculus,
linear algebra, and math that
apply to trading and finance.
You'll also find courses
on gravitational physics,
astronomy, and machine learning.
And you can level up in
just five minutes a day
by working on the daily challenge.
Each daily challenge
provides you with the context
and framework that you
need to complete it.
So you don't have to take a
deep dive if you don't want to.
No need to make your brain bleed.
Now you can sign up and
start learning today for free
at brilliant.org/legaleagle.
And the first 200 people to sign up
will also get 20% off
their annual subscription.
So just click on the link
that's on screen right now
or in the description to get
20% off your subscription
to Brilliant.
Plus clicking that link
really helps out this channel.
And while you're there,
click on this link with all
of my other legal videos.
So click on this link or
I'll see you in court.